come Jesus I just noticed them yeah you
better be careful I want you to be
careful I know I have to be careful but
these are I'm not saying this
confidently good Jean
I bought him oh really I went into a
store and I bought them now in Calgary
yeah
now hold on tight all the oil workers
give them to you excuse me these are
these are sort of dungarees but they're
gray then they go well with certainly
length no you when I stand this low you
haven't crate on my rump
you rub never looks better in jeans then
I go now George I got a woman who's
gonna help you out with this and you're
gonna come in and I go she's gonna help
you out with your perversion let George
Lucas is a bad example because he's not
a pervert he's amazing I'm just saying
but Harvey Weinstein let's say Harvey
wants if Harvey was a deal Harvard let's
use Harvey Weinstein instead I'd say he
didn't do start well right now you can
make or break my career with a phone
call this woman right here
her name is Brendan ax and Brendan ax
brendan is gonna give you a little what
for and then I would have you [ __ ]
toss him around beat him up and jujitsu
the [ __ ] out of him just come talk no no
I have what you're missing okay have you
pretzel em until he had to suck his own
dick you understand I go well we're not
gonna secretary but he's gonna bend your
well let's wrap this bit up all I'm
saying is if a big-time director when
you were 30 struggling yeah was like yo
you're gonna be the next Harrison Ford
all you got to do is jack me off with
your feet yeah
would you do it no just go to your dream
why am i sweating sweating and now
George Lucas asked you to Jack mouth
with his feet and the path line between
the T answer is I've never been that
desperate so I don't know but I will
tell you that I know a famous guy who
was super he was broke his [ __ ] before
he made it taking a piss and a guy came
in and goes I'll suck your dick for 1500
bucks and my friend was like oh he's
straight as hell you know god damn it's
so much money right now that's so much
money and he really had to think about
it yeah life is a battle and he and then
he's religious so he was like I don't
think this is I think I'm gonna pay for
this later so it died he wanted the
money so
I'm not doing it he walked away why do
you think they don't show scores at the
end of rounds I feel the upside of
showing score significally outweighs the
downside um
I agree I would like to see the scores
you know you I I think it would be
better and I also think the corner man
could go oh [ __ ] we thought you're up
you actually go into you have to win
this and win this fight so yeah I agree
I don't see a lot of cons with that I
don't mind doing what boxing does we
have an unofficial scorecard cuz now
it's kind of very like here say like
Rogan like I you know who knows you know
they kind of to stay neutral like you
see I can Accor you know Dominick Cruz
or DC like I think I give that round to
this guy but I think you could designate
someone who's not in the arena who's
watching it on TV which typically is a
better way to watch a fight so you can
see more angles and it's more clear and
I think they should and they're gonna be
experts but you have to have the same
guy every time I don't know who that is
it has to be the expert who knows the
fight game and he scores it by round
like a ko if they actually tried that at
least try it out I don't know why you
wouldn't yeah dropping Osby yeah I
wanted to I heard a really awesome quote
because you know one of the things I say
in today's political climate and just
our culture is that it's really easy to
be against something but it's a lot
harder before something because when
you're for something
it's you've got a kind of like really
work out the details and a belief system
and so Michelangelo said the great why
do you love what is happening right now
this is my dropping on this is my
dropping knowledge this is like a
segment you guys do blind yeah I mean
I'm so rarely a guest on this show we
have a guest we're gonna do it now and I
get your take on this okay make live so
I said that's so funny had no idea what
I was doing I just come out you made a
Twix she came round you're here loudly
what the [ __ ] going on right fixing my
hair will make my final thoughts with
Jerry Springer
and I just died but I believe it was the
great Michelangelo I believe why are you
calling a Michelangelo Michelangelo why
do you kid well cuz I'm I'm Italian oh
you are yeah that's weird cuz I'm
Italian
my father owns an Italian restaurant my
mom's Italian but I've never heard
anybody
I think it's Michelangelo well that's
because you're American
Nicoll Italian so Michelangelo